hey they're pioneers today I'm going to
talk you through two intensity
techniques you can use to create some
truly punishing and brutal workouts
so on today's menu we have two intensity
techniques they are burns and frost sets
we're going to start with burns as you
might have guessed burns do what they
say on the tin they make your muscles
burn you should recognize the burn from
your most intense workouts if not you'll
know that you've reached it because it
feels something like this
so that's the burn and there that's
their name snake let's take a look at
the move so the idea of burns is they're
basically like a partial or partial is
an exercise we don't complete through
the full range of motion say worse
that's a curl excuse me I've just been a
big workout so my arms are like dead
which is perfect for this sort of thing
so that's where that's a curl that's a
partial because you're only doing a
little bit of the movement you can also
do part over the top burns are kind of
like involuntary partials you're doing a
partial because you can't do anything
else you've exhausted the muscle to that
point so you do a normal set to the
point of failure we can't do any more
and then you literally squeeze out the
last drop of weight you can do like say
if you're hanging from a pull-up bar
you might literally just bob up and down
slightly to complete those last few six
if I was doing that for grows then the
burn might look something like this it's
just literally the last you can do and
you'll find that you can do fewer and
fewer smaller and smaller movements
until eventually you just give up
altogether and then you've completely
exhausted the muscle you've presumably
torn a hole on a muscle fiber
you've flooded the muscle with
metabolites to trigger growth you've
massively increased your time and
attention
takes a bit long to recover for the next
step but yes brutal and the great thing
about burns is quite versatile so one
technique I like to use is during a set
I'll do an isometric hold like so just
hold it in place now normally these
would be for you like for me I'd run out
quickly but like I said I pretty
exhausted so what you do something that
faster is like okay I'm even going
anymore you do little burns like stay
until you know that then it's hard then
you hold it try no matter that got to do
something on this side I'll be uneven
nope never got these sorts of techniques
make make you I was just doing that in
the German yeah they are suspect yes
they say you were doing a pull-up
and you're doing an isometric hold like
so maybe you can sit there for hours
probably not
imagine you can you could just do this a
little bit to start with slowly just to
kind of make it that bit more difficult
and then do the isometric hold again
great way to get a massive burn which
almost always triggers growth
subsequently when you rest okay and the
next technique is flush sets so these
were going to need a slightly lighter
weight okay probably not that light but
I am yeah don't fall this is what I'm
reduced to so the idea with this with a
flush set is that you're just going to
do a massive set with a really light
weight so say normally you curl 20s
maybe do five or seven and then you do
something like 20 30 some flush sets
even go to 75 I mean this is ridiculous
because now these are toys II honest but
yeah you would you would do something a
bit heavier than that but then you just
do this massive set though that's for
like yeah like I say 30 to 75 reps and
what you're doing there is really
flooding their muscles with blood and I
don't know whether you subscribe to
occlusion which is where you but total
ket around your muscles but this can do
the same thing of occlusion it basically
traps the blood in the muscle really
triggering massive growth and there are
two ways that I like to use a flush set
either at the end of my workout as a
kind of finisher it's also a little bit
cardio you're going to fight fast and
that just again exhausts the very last
bit of effort I have left in those
muscles all right at the start a short
one then maybe thirty reps and that's a
way of making your warmup step a little
less boring and lame and at the same
time it gets on a pre burn and anything
you do subsequently is going to feel
about ten times more difficult as a
result so there you go those are burns
and brush sets and you can use them
together on the road to make your
workouts much more intense and there's
something different so if you've done it
before try it in your next workout
adding something new in almost always
helps you to mix things up stimulate
growth and bus plateaus they hope you
found that helpful and also just
consider that this is the sort of thing
you can use to make your workout so much
Hardy Aventine you exercise it's
necessary just
the pace looks at the speed and just do
what you can feel it's working because
gradually you'll get in tune with your
body you learn to feel when something is
really likely to stimulate gratefully
getting a really good workout in so just
do what you can make it hurt you know in
a good way and and you'll get growth so
hope you found it helpful
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time bye for now